[Music]
this is the world 200 million years ago
no cell phones electricity or even other
humans would you be able to survive in
this new world could you get yourself a
pet dinosaur wait dinosaurs are here
okay maybe this won't be so bad this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you were alive 200 million years ago the
world was pretty different during the
Late Triassic period one of the most
notable differences is this right here
this is Pangaea a supercontinent
containing different parts of today's
world there's Australia down south North
America in the northwest and Eurasia in
the east all interconnected it would
take you a while but in theory you could
walk from California to France you won't
see the Hollywood Walk of Fame or see
the Eiffel Tower as they don't exist yet
what would you see the first thing you'd
notice as you're traveling across
Pangaea are all the dinosaurs running
about you won't have to worry about
dinosaurs such as the DeLong that way
only 11 kilograms
they won't pose much of a threat but
watch out for the melon or a soros who
has a height of 12 meters and would find
you to be a tasty snack scientists say
that the Late Triassic period was the
dawn of the first dinosaurs dinosaurs of
all sizes would be everywhere you'd also
see some other crazy creatures you've
never seen before and some that may
remind you of animals you see today this
species known as the drop an asaurus
with its reptile like skin and arched
back might be one of the first versions
of birds to ever exist
the Triassic period was an incredibly
important 50 million years of evolution
a time with not a lot of competition
between species since just prior to this
period 70% of Earth's creatures were
wiped out in a mass extinction event
many of the animals at the time were
able to thrive and grow without having
to be constantly wary of other predators
the further you travel inland in Japan
gia you'll notice the massive weather
changes the outer edges of the
supercontinent may be full of lush
forests
Greengrass but the further you go in
that begins to change scientists suspect
that much of Pangea was a dry desert
wasteland that's because the landmass
was so large that the interior wouldn't
have received the cooling effects of the
ocean
speaking of which the ocean known as
Panthalassa surrounded all of Pangaea
and covered 70% of Earth's surface this
ocean was extremely deadly it could
easily produce super hurricanes and
monsoons and due to its massive size
they could gain enough momentum to hit
Pangaea with potentially fatal weather
Pangaea was just beginning to separate
200 million years ago if you were able
to stick around a few million more years
for the Jurassic period that's when
you'd truly see dinosaurs thrive the
t-rex Brachiosaurus
Stegosaurus what would happen if they
were still alive today well that sounds
like a question for another what-if